[Music]
welcome back so we're walking through
different uses of the singular value
decomposition for image compression for
dimensionality reduction and for least
squares regression and so here I'm gonna
walk you through how to use the SVD for
least squares linear regression models
in Python so here's a jupiter notebook
this was converted by daniel Daluz key
all of the code is at databook u-dub
comm and we're gonna work out how you
can use use the SVD to build these
linear regression models from data okay
so I think this is a pretty fun example
and I would always point out if you want
to use a mathematical tool like the
pseudo-inverse or a least squares model
it's good to practice using it on a
system where you know the answer where
you actually know what the with the
right answer is so you can see if your
method is working before you apply it to
new data where you might not know the
answer so here what we're gonna do is
we're gonna have data pairs a and B so
these are going to be kind of scatter
plots of data that we believe has some
linear relationship and we're gonna try
to find the best fit line with slope x
so that a x equals B we're going to try
to solve for X that is in some sense
minimizes the sum of the squares of the
errors of all of these blue points from
this yellow line okay that's the least
squares solution and we can solve for it
using using this the singular value
decomposition okay and what I'm going to
show you is we're gonna start with data
where we actually build it knowing the
answer so we're going to start with data
where we we know the slope of the line
and we literally build B from that model
and then we're gonna see if we can
discover that slope but everything I'm
going to show you generalizes to the
higher dimensional case where where
maybe I have a times x equals B where
there are multiple factors a that we're
going to use to build a model for B so
there might be multiple columns in this
a matrix there might be multiple
measurements of different A's a 1 a 2 a
3 and
gonna build a model of B based on all of
that so that's what this really is is
this is building models from data so I
have a bunch of data of A's and B's and
I'm gonna try to build a model of
basically the slope of ax equals B so
that in the future if I have a new data
point a I can predict what the outcome B
will be just by multiplying by that
slope X so that's a really rudimentary
model but that is in the spirit of lots
of machine learning models nowadays
where you build kind of these
predictions from data okay and in this
case what we would do is we would have
the SVD of the a matrix here so we have
a equals u Sigma V transpose and we
could build our best fit X tilde by
taking the pseudo inverse of a so we can
invert these matrices one by one and we
would get u transpose Sigma inverse V so
this is the least squares solution the
kind of a pseudo inverse solution for
the best fit slope given that matrix
that information in a and n B so if you
measured a and B you can find this slope
and this generalizes to higher
dimensional distributions where you have
multiple input directions a and some
output variable B good so here we're
going to cook up data for kind of this a
the single input single output system
where we know the slope is 3 and we're
gonna build a uniform distribution of a
points we're going to multiply them by 3
to get B and then we're gonna add some
white noise on to that so that it looks
a little noisy okay that's what we're
gonna do here is take X times a plus
some random noise okay and then I'm
gonna plot those points and I'm gonna
plot the true line and then what we're
gonna do is we're going to compute this
best fit line using the SVD down here so
we're gonna take the SVD of a we're
gonna get our u R Sigma and our V
transpose we're gonna build this least
squares best estimate for u tilde just
like when I wrote here its V transpose
transpose is V
inverse of Sigma times u transpose times
B and then we're gonna plot the true
line the approximate line and the data
all on top of each other so that's what
we're seeing here let's run it and you
can actually see it's pretty good okay
so the true line is this this white line
here and even from those noisy blue X's
you get a pretty good estimate of that
line slope in yellow here this is our
best fit regression line it's pretty
darn accurate just from this noisy data
and if I if I decrease the amount of
noise on my data so I tighten the
distribution of these blue X's or if I
had more data points this line would
just get better and better okay so
that's relatively easy to do if I wanted
to I could just say instead of instead
of points every 0.25 space to 0.25 apart
I could space them more closely point 1
apart and in principle of my line just
gets better and better ok so this is a
really really simple example you don't
technically need the SVD of your of your
a here but I'm showing you this in a way
that would generalize to data that had
multiple input factors ok and just to
point out there are other ways of
computing this best slope line so this
is the SVD approach that we just used
this is X tilde 1 you can also use the P
inverse the pseudo-inverse it's exactly
the same thing that's what this is is
the pseudo inverse of a times B there's
a third method we have in the book
regress B comma a but that's only
specific to MATLAB so really you have to
use these two these two commands in in
Python okay so very easy to take data
pairs a and B and build a model for the
slope that relates those that you could
then use in the future ok thank you